sous ces ruines fumantes des centaines
de civils et de combattants
retranché dans le dédale de couloirs
souterrains de la série age of talent de
marioupol à l'extérieur les militaires
russes guettent la moindre sortie est en
théorie ne sont pas censés combattre
moscou a annoncé un cessez-le-feu de
trois jours à partir de ce jeudi matin
pour permettre l'évacuation des civils
pris au piège dans le dernier bastion de
la résistance ukrainienne à marioupol
notre commandant en chef a ordonné d'
annuler les assaut contre le complexe
d'azov stalles il n'ya pas d'assaut il
ya des accrochages mais ils sont dus aux
combattants ukrainien qui tendait sortie
pour reprendre leur position de tir ce
mercredi la série age of talent
subissait encore un bombardement
intensif comme le montrent ces images
diffusées par les séparatistes pro
russes eux-mêmes eux ont échappé à ces
bombardements ils font partie de la
centaine de civils évacués de lusine
grâce à un premier cessez le feu
dimanche dernier
quand on était dans les sous-sols
parfois je regrettais d'avoir un bébé
parce que j'étais émotionnellement
dévasté parfois ne joue même pas de la
nourriture pour lui le président
ukrainien appelle au respect de ce
cessez le feu annoncé
nous espérons continuer à soutenir
legend of talent il y a encore des
civils là bas des femmes des enfants
pour les sauver nous devons maintenir le
cessez-le-feu la partie ukrainienne est
prête à le faire ailleurs dans le pays
les combats se poursuivent moscou
affirme avoir simulé des tirs de missile
à capacité nucléaire